um is there like a fight that you really
want is there a fight that you
does it change day to day week to week
like a month ago if i'd
asked you was it a different person than
today so a month ago if you would ask me
i would have said
you know it's tony ferguson um but then
after habib we saw my retiring and then
justin gates he was talking about
fighting within six to eight weeks
and then also connor and poirier were
talking about fighting 170 dana white
has made it very clear
if those guys are fighting 170 they're
not going to be you know
they obviously aren't going to be
getting a title shot you know anytime
soon
um as soon as habib retired you know i
was like hey man i'll fight justin
gaichi
next week for the title six weeks from
now november december [ __ ] i'll fight
him at the breakfast but
yeah i'll fight him next tomorrow
morning before the plane takes off you
know
let's just keep keep the octagon set up
let's go
uh you know so so that was then so at
that point you that
you're like yeah so khabib's retired
they kind of changed things it changed
things and i said hey i'll fight i'll
fight dustin
or i'll fight tony or gaichi
for you know whether it's the number one
contender spot or whether it's for the
title because you had connor and
and poirier talking about fighting 170.
so they were almost out of the
discussion
still right now you have connor and
poirier it looks like it's almost done
it looks like they're gonna be fighting
in 155 so those two are booked yeah
gachi who just fought so
chances are he might want a little bit
of time off
so i think tony ferguson i i say tony
ferguson for two reasons number one
he makes the most sense because he's
been the guy who set out the longest and
secondly
if i if i do think habib is coming back
i would say
he's beaten connor khabib has beaten
conor he's beaten pourier
he's beaten gaichi now and he the only
fight left out there for him was the
ferguson fight but if i've
beat ferguson i leap frog ferguson and
now you get chandler habib for
his 30-0 fight or 29-1
fight instead of tony ferguson so that
kind of gives me the best option to
to win leap frog him fight a top five
guy and
be the most appealing match up the most
challenging matchup for
habit or magametto wow was it
disappointing um
when and have you talked to tony about
it you guys had some exchange about it
right
we didn't exchange a little bit um and
then even he he commented on one of my
instagram posts like
train hard see you soon you know yeah
he's such a unique guy he's such like a
yeah he's such a he is anomaly he's an
anomaly he's a unique guy you don't know
you don't know
you don't know what he's going to say
and then you also don't know what he's
going to do inside the cage
you know so it's wild and it's just like
i think it's a perfect it's
a fight that scares me you know so it's
a fight that's great you know it's great
for me it's great from great
introduction for me
so he's a top five guy he's a scary guy
he was 12-0 before
he was on a 12-fight win streak before
he lost his last fight we can't forget
that like he's still
one of the most dangerous guys in the
division definitely the most
unpredictable guy and how quickly that
gets forgotten after the gates you fight
he's in a crate i mean how quickly
suddenly he's like he seems
like there's this uh you know yeah he's
not the same guy
exactly and granted he took a lot of
damage in that fight but still
man like we all take damage you know we
all win or lose we take damage you know
uh so it's just it is a very much
and that's the hardest thing about it
but i think it's also the most beautiful
thing about it
because the some of the fans do realize
what us fighters have to go through like
that our head is on the chopping block
essentially every single time we fight
where it's like man it's it's a what
have you done for me lately business
but going back to like you were talking
about poirier it's like it's cool to see
his
he he's become a hero win or lose he's
been one of those guys who are going to
come in if he wins people love him if he
loses people are
rooting for him wanting to pick himself
back up and get back in the win column
and i looked at myself that kind of same
way i'm gonna
i'm gonna come into the ufc no matter
what i might have you know five fights
left in me 12 fights left to me but
either way there's a bunch of big fights
out there for me to just have a blast to
be put on this
you know awesome platform who knows i
could go 500 the next
six fights i could go 8-0 my next eight
fights i could win the title and
hold it for 10 years i don't know you
know so we'll see good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah